isn't he cute that can be dangerous just
like this episode conquest of cuteness
or as a by cuteness of cuteness conquest
of cuteness it can be so cute it can
make you forget the title this is cup I
okay so they're these hoping do they
have a name not that I know of I just
realize yeah okay so they're these
little thing they just sort of look like
star like puff balls or like dim song or
something I don't know these little
Japanese roles are something that just
are really friggin adorable and they
want to win battles and take over stuff
and things like that so they tried to
take over Finn and Jake making their
everything burrito which is the concept
I love Oh we'll get the board game in
play there's actually a board game how
do you I'm not saying you can't but how
do you make a board game out of the
everything burrito I don't know I'll
purchase it and we can play that'd be
fun we should film that too okay so uh
so give to make that everything burrito
and these cute things gum and they're
like you know we want to take you over
but they're too adorable and they I just
realized it's like knowing the end of
this now there's certain things that
happen this they're just really like dis
are ly kind of pointless like like there
they go to sleep Jake's afraid does
everything burrito is contaminated or
something cuz they threaten like enjoy
your burrito so he buries it which is
hilarious which how do you bury
everything but they they somehow did and
yeah then they're like before the good
event they're like you know something
reminds them of their mom and fret just
their mom which is already like what
it's the way that it's what Finn said he
said Jake goes you reminds me of mom
always saying the right the right thing
at the right time
hey you know amazes reminds me of mom
and then Jake said things like their mom
I guess yeah so I don't know exactly had
to take that but I I now have this
strange hybrid of what the mother
but didn't we see Jake's mom at some
point or no did we just see his dad like
in the flashbacks we saw the dad we saw
the brother and actually if you remember
back to boom yes I'm aware my daughter
sitting there going this memory sis boom
boom Mountain remember the dogs had
picked up thin think back no you mind me
though you just kissed a boom-boom baby
okay kind of that was also Jake's dad
and Jake's mom okay so but that probably
can't be Finn's mom really ish
I guess what no I'm just saying that
you've already seen Jake's mom yeah yeah
so the idea of the name of the same mom
it's like I'm pretty sure Finn and Jake
don't you have the same mom but it could
it could be like I don't know though I
think I can figure it's like they there
because it's like his pet or their Cali
brothers almost that they just serve
associated with the same mom-ish kind of
but I don't know it was definitely very
interesting because you're like that's
the first mention he ever says of his
parents you just don't even think of
Finn having a parents in this world but
as it goes on it's like you know the
sort of apocalypse thing they're hinting
at and stuff like that and just what
happened and the mushroom Wars which is
probably like mushroom clouds apocalypse
tours oh I thought it because I know it
was these guys because they're running
and attacking with mushrooms no could be
that's what you think of this um okay so
we have a very slight finger so they go
and and they imitate the mother and at
that whole scene where they're trying to
break in was very interesting because
it's very uh yeah that was just really
show us actually play there like as
we're talking but um so they go in and I
really kind of liked that scene because
if you know Adventure Time there's these
big battles and stuff like that and you
feel kind of like the only way I can put
it is like when they break the window
everything was so downplayed now saying
oh my stuff that sucks how they can fix
that window wait why am I even
questioning that I realize is because
they wrote her down play you know these
things running around and it's dark and
they're afraid of a blanket and you know
when they final it's like shake it I
don't know it's it seemed a little bit
more like if you were really the
situation what would you do with these
things I shake it or something and to
get caught in little areas and stuff so
I like that because I never really felt
a situation like that before Adventure
Time so they say when it or are they say
if I gotta go get an army and attack but
they literally kill themselves just
going over a field because they're
apathetic so they fall apart
yeah they just explode which I like so
finally they decide would it be great if
we just let them win so they can have a
victory and they let the cute king which
is so clearly a woman doing the voice
but I guess that that has to stop like
whatever like LSP you're like doctor
girlfriend from venture times I mean
that's there's that still main point
women to obviously and just doesn't kind
of like you yeah why behave these
alright easy to hide um so yeah and so
they let them win and then at the end
they say you can use your couldn't good
or acuteness for like whoa nipple Asian
and stuff and they manipulate the Ice
King well you forget because they that
the the cute the cuteness wins but Jake
can't take it any longer because he's
being tickled because of the victory
dance ah and the cute people realize
that it's ketchup a nut blood hmm and
that's when they're like oh you can
totally you should cuteness to rule and
all that stuff yeah I will say this it
is nice to see like even if it is
something it's very tiny order it is
nice to see another king anyway we only
had the Ice King and that's it
nice King know said be at least one more
I I keep thinking there's like one other
but it's like it's a kingdom ruled by
princesses for whatever reason there's
like no other hierarchy except the Ice
King there's just a few others down the
road I know that
and technically xergiok was a king now
okay there's my two others um there are
some good jokes in this one the one that
really made me laugh hard which I like
well then going across the field was
pretty funny and not even making it to
the door but the part where they're
they're gonna let them wait
and then they come together like this
giant transformer which alone is
hilarious could you think that Joe is
gonna go oh they actually are gonna beat
them like for real
but then when he back off you see the
hole that's all and that's that's very
funny I thought that was he and I love
the design - how they come together and
I think like these two hands are just
reaching to hold onto the big face but
horns like these mean eyebrows yeah but
I like this I thought that was very
clever uh the only thing actually I
didn't like uh I thought they could
flick cuter
I bet see to me because I used to do
like I said like illustrations and stuff
a lot of times I had to draw cute things
if you want something to be cute you
usually give them really big expressive
eyes that's usually what doesn't like
sometimes you can get away with not but
yeah you either have to make like
everything around them like especially
fluffy or cuddly or whatever to give
them the dies just a couple circles and
not much else it's more like the voice
is what skewing the fact that they're
tiny but because I thought it would have
I thought what an even funnier if they
really have like it was just like an
army of kittens or something like that
like with the big expressive eyes and
the little noses and mouths like like
that one bit funnier but I like to find
and I like the anything where there's
something really threatening or
something that wants to be threatening
but they're really adorable they're so
not threatening always gets a big laugh
but they still have the idea that they
are something to be reckoned with that's
why I really like that cute King I like
you know how are we supposed to dance in
their brains if we can't even get past
the field and you know I love Becky low
voice talking about you know swimming in
the brains yeah that's really funny but
uh no I did I liked it I mean I was uh
you know nothing great though that
insight with the mother was very
fascinating that did sort of maybe go
like well but that's a better term cute
episode this what do you think well
you're a bit more talkative today than
normal
I'm sorry no no it's okay cuz I mean you
pretty much said everything I wanted to
say no I'm sorry again no no the only
thing you failed to mention which is
something that's actually kind of
important is
BMO's a camera hello I I guess I sort of
just assumed that would go without
saying but they finally said it that's
an important piece of information that's
finally been said is it really yes have
you not noticed up until this point that
there's no pictures of anything no
there's pictures of stuff I don't know
what you're getting at
do you mo take pictures of the
apocalypse what did he take pictures of
that naked woman that got ripped oh
you're a pervert there's a naked picture
that's ripped like that probably no it's
a fun cute episode I mean I disagree
that they had to be cuter I thought they
were cute enough they were fine in this
world they were quite cute included I
mean like I got the point I like I said
and the voice is really what soul did
those come on the cute King had a smiley
face on his butt that was funny cuz I
like how a lot of them had like extra
faces but how much foyer would have been
if there was like a I'm not trying to
think of like a cute Kathleen faces like
normal normal from garfi or something
like that was like the faces on that'd
be too cute and then it would get to the
point like Garfield with nermal where
you just want to kick the crowd you
legitimately don't want to like them I
don't know I think you could do it again
like it's fine it's serviceable you know
but yes but like a car yeah a very cute
car like the Wienermobile is very cute
the Wienermobile yeah I don't like how
excited you get when I said that I like
weiners wait a minute
I see what you were doing that it's
nicely done
yes if they had a smiley face at the end
of the wiener will be like that you
really like that that's pretty gross
yeah yeah yeah so uh anything to wrap up
on no no no you said it all seriously
you you pretty much hit everything on
the head
this one I don't need you anymore I know
pretty much yeah moment you don't need
me just say goodbye and I'll leave
goodbye
no chick please